everyone Peter Brown here with a
gamespot news update you know windows 8
right it's the operating system that
comes with all new pcs well Microsoft's
getting ready to replace it and what
comes after 810 of course that's right
Windows 10 is designed to be the last
major update to the windows line so
smaller more frequent updates could be
expected that is their excuse for
calling it Windows 10 instead of I don't
know windows 9 a joke from the
conference where the OS was announced
suggested the name windows one although
that name was already taken Windows 10
is also being designed to run on the
broadest range of devices including
phones tablets PCs and consoles it's too
early to say if the xbox one will ever
be updated to windows 10 but pictures
from the event do show Windows 10
running on a TV next to a connect so a
console running Windows 10 is definitely
an eventual possibility as far as
updates to the operating system over
windows 8 we haven't seen too many
specifics although the start menu
appears to be back as a compromise
between Windows 7 and the Metro screen
from Windows 8 more detailed info on
Windows 10 head on over to gamespot
sister sites seen it and for all your
gaming news stay tuned to gamespot com